after quite a tough year somerset  academy losee campus holding a special  ceremony today  to celebrate their 2021 graduates 119  students don their caps and gallons with  their families and friends in attendance  like many other schools across the  valley  this is the first time these students  are gathering together in months the  school's principal says  she's so proud of every single person  who persevered through a global pandemic  and then graduated here today  enjoy what's left of you know the summer  and i look forward to seeing what you do  in the future  they've survived a lot of craziness with  online school and they've shown a lot of  grit and perseverance and i'm just  really proud of them  there were a few special guests in  attendance as well including the nellis  air force base honor guard